welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Flynt Leverett a senior fellow at the
Jackson Institute for Global Affairs at
Yale and a senior research fellow at the
new america foundation in Washington DC
from 1992 to 2003 mr. Leverett served as
senior director for Middle East affairs
at the National Security Council on the
secretary of state's policy planning
staff and as a CIA senior analyst mr.
Levitz articles and op-ed on Iran other
Middle East issues and global energy
affairs have been published in numerous
media outlets today we'll talk with mr.
Leverett about American grand strategy
in the Middle East and his opinion that
we are on the road to failure in this
critical region welcome mr. Leverett
thanks good to be with you he recently
gave a talk at Yale University and you
argued that the u.s. is grand strategy
in the Middle East is at serious risk
for strategic failure just so we're on
the same page what do you mean by grand
strategy the best one sentence
definition of grand strategy I know
comes from a smart political scientist
at MIT Barry Posen who describes it as a
state's theory of how best to cause
security for itself I think that's a
really powerful one sentence definition
but let me unpack it on a couple of
levels one is the notion of grand
strategy is a very comprehensive
all-encompassing a sort of sort of
concept some of the I think some of the
most important work that Paul Kennedy
the great historian here at Yale has
done has been to educate us to think
about grand strategy in these
comprehensive terms there is certainly a
military component but it goes well
beyond that diplomacy is at least as
important a part of grand strategy the
ability
of a state to through diplomacy to
reduce the number of its adversaries in
the international arena and to increase
the number of states that are willing to
work with it cooperate with it in
various ways that's an important part of
grand strategy economics economic power
is an important part of grand strategy
not necessarily so much in coercive
terms the ability to course others
economically but the ability to attract
others through your your economic
prosperity quality so I think that's an
important dimension to it that it's
about using all the tools of national
power and national policy to promote the
interests of a state not just in wartime
but but just as importantly if not more
so in in peacetime the other dimension
that I think it's important to to unpack
is that grand strategy is really about
the calculated relationship of means to
ends it's about how you take all these
various tools of national power not just
military but these other tools as well
and how you relate them to promoting and
advancing the most important interest
that state has and that's when I talk
about American grand strategy in the
Middle East that's really what I'm
trying to get at is how the United
States not just in any one
administration but across presidential
administrations not just over four year
term but over decades how the United
States goes about has gone about and
we'll go about trying to promote its
most important interests in this very
important part of the world what are the
elements of the US is grand strategy
toward the middle east I would identify
three elements that let me call them
traditional elements and then I think
there's a fourth one that's been added
on to the agenda more recently the the
three traditional elements of Mayor
eric and grand strategy in the Middle
East are first of all the provision of
energy security by protecting the
physical security of oil flows coming
out of the Persian Gulf this is
something on which the the world economy
depends and by providing this this kind
of energy security the u.s. presents
itself as doing it as a kind of
international public good it is
something that all states can benefit
from it gives the United States an
important strategic role not just in the
region but it also bolsters American
claims to global leadership and global
economic leadership even at a time when
the American economy isn't isn't going
so well and when America's international
financial position has deteriorated
quite a bit over the last decade or so
the United States still plays this very
unique role in providing this
international public good of energy
security so I think that's one important
long-standing elements American grand
strategy region a second would be trying
to encourage negotiated settlements the
various unresolved tracks of the
arab-israeli conflict American
politicians may not like to talk about
it in public very much but I think in in
policy settings in Washington there is a
very widespread recognition that there
is at least a potential for conflict
between America's interest in providing
energy security the way that I've
defined it by protecting the flow of oil
flows out of the persian gulf between
that interest and america's commitment
to a secure israel in theory at least
the peace process is the way that
successive us administrations have tried
to reconcile the any potential conflicts
between those two interests so that's a
second element a third element is that
the United States has tried over several
decades to foster a balance of power in
the region that is favorable to the
United States and its regional allies
um we typically like to divide up the
region into what we call moderate states
that are we say are interested in
stability Israel the Arab states that
have made peace with Israel other
moderate Arab states Saudi Arabian the
GCC states for example at least until
recently we would most American
politicians what I think have put turkey
in that category we have this moderate
camp on the other side we have account
we like to call radicals who are
presumably interested only in
instability the Islamic Republic of Iran
more often than not Syria various
non-state actors like Hamas Hezbollah
least until 2003 Libya might have fit in
that category and what we wanted to do
over over many years as Henry Kissinger
put it so well we want to basically
bolster the position of moderates in the
region and marginalize radicals so those
I think have been the three kind of
long-standing pillars of American grand
strategy in the region since nine eleven
we've added a fourth I think and that is
we don't want this region broadly
defined again to be a platform for
launching mass casualty terrorist
attacks against the American homeland or
other important American interests so I
think those are the basic elements of
American grand strategy in the Middle
East and what do you think is going
wrong well I think what has gone wrong
is the way in which we've we've tried to
pursue these four elements of our grand
strategy in the region the way in which
we've gone about it has grown
increasingly dysfunctional over sign I'd
identify at least a couple of different
things one is in terms of our military
posture in the region until relatively
recently we have operated in the region
as what you might
call an offshore balancer in other words
from the time that we took on this
responsibility of defending the physical
flow of oil out of the Persian Gulf we
did not at least initially we did not
try to do this by putting large numbers
of American boots on the ground we built
up a very robust naval presence in the
Gulf which we maintain we arranged all
kinds of pre positioning of military
equipment basing arrangements in various
places so that in the event of a crisis
we could surge conventional ground
forces tactical air forces into the
region but we didn't seek to deploy
those kinds of forces there in large
numbers on a permanent or ongoing basis
this is the way we fought the first Gulf
War after Saddam Hussein ordered his
armies to invade Kuwait we surged ground
forces conventional tactical air forces
into the region and with our naval
presence there use that as the basis for
expelling Iraqi forces from Kuwait I
think one of our biggest mistakes has
been we have basically gotten away from
offshore balancing as the defining
framework for a military posture in the
region we started this right after the
first Gulf War when we did not really
withdraw ground forces and tactical air
forces from the region following the end
of the Iraqi occupation of Kuwait we
kept troops on the ground and I come
back to admit why I think that was such
a disastrous decision but then we
compounded that after nine eleven with
not just the invasion of Afghanistan
which was actually something for which
we had a large amount of regional
support but we then got into a prolonged
occupation of Afghanistan which is still
basically going on and then we also
invaded Iraq and had a prolonged
occupation
of Iraq so we were no longer an offshore
balancer operating from this kind of
over the horizon military posture we
became in the eyes of most people in the
region and on the ground occupier right
now I think this had really really
profoundly negative consequences for the
United States first of all it is
directly counterproductive to our
counterterrorism goals I can draw you a
direct line from the decision to keep
forces on the ground particularly in
Saudi Arabia after the first Gulf War to
the 911 attacks bin Laden other senior
figures in al qaeda al qaeda emerged
basically in opposition to and what they
would describe as resistance to american
occupation of the Muslim holy land it is
politically convenient in popular in the
United States to say that al Qaeda
Muslim extremists attacked us on 911
because they hate our values we let
women drive we have religious toleration
all these things I mean you can just
read their websites read their
statements they don't really care what
we do in our own infidel country what
they care about is what we do in their
countries and what particularly when
they perceive is as occupying the
Arabian Peninsula the birthplace of
Islam where the two holiest places on
the planet for believing Muslims are
located that is something which is going
to draw a negative response and that
negative response culminated in the 911
attacks we then compounded that by
invading and occupying other Muslim
countries Afghanistan Iraq there are now
very very good statistical analyses
which show that the level of
anti-american terrorism has actually
increased dramatically since nine eleven
and in particular since the invasion and
occupation
of Iraq and this is directly
counterproductive to what we say our
counterterrorism goals in the region I
also think in the end invasion and
occupation in the Middle East it just
doesn't work very well you know it
underscores the limits of American
military power which diminishes our
strategic standing in the region and I
think it also really for many regional
constituencies whether we like it or not
it fundamentally calls into question the
legitimacy of our purposes in the region
very few people in the region believe we
are actually doing good by prolonged
occupation of Afghanistan by prolonged
occupation of Iraq and we are really
undermining the legitimacy of American
engagement in the region by by doing
that finally to say even for countries
outside the region like China it really
has called into question whether we
really are providing a public good
saying the form of energy security from
a Chinese perspective the way the United
States has acted militarily in the
region over the last several years it's
actually more of a threat to Chinese
energy security that it is a help at
least in their in their perception and I
think that to create some real damage
for our international position the
second thing that we've done that I
think is really really hurt us is we
basically have tanked on providing any
meaningful leadership on arab-israeli
diplomacy there are a couple of
different dimensions to this one just in
terms of how we act as a mediator we
love to say that we can't want peace
more than the parties but the factor
matter is we can in fact well peace more
than the parties and the reality is we
almost certainly do want peace more than
the parties but
we have let ourselves be put in a
position where we basically don't want
to do anything in the peace process
which will make any particular sitting
Israeli government uncomfortable so
we've effectively tanked on providing
meaningful leadership in that in that
process beyond that we have essentially
bought an Israeli argument that Israeli
security requires something that's
tantamount to Israeli military hegemony
in the region that israel needs to be
able to use force first or at least
unilaterally anytime anywhere for more
or less any purpose that it deems
desirable and that has really i think
undermined American credibility in the
region and done real damage to our
standing and influence we are no longer
seen as strategically dominant power in
the region that's actually trying to
solve problems for people in the region
we are seen as basically a power with
hegemonic aspirations which is creating
instability furthering conflict and
backing Israel in what is widely seen as
its hegemonic ambitions in the region I
think that has done real damage as well
so how do we get back on the road to
recovery so to speak um what do we need
to do several things one is I think it's
really important that we return to this
offshore balance or roll with an over
the horizon military posture you know
the troops that we have on the ground in
Iraq in Afghanistan they are not serving
a positive long-term strategic purpose
for the United States and we should be
moving back as rapidly as possible to
this over the horizon posture that's one
thing secondly I would really avoid
another what I would call a war of
choice in
Middle East if we are going to have
another war in the Middle East it will
be a war with Iran it will be a war that
the United States initiates and it will
be a war that the United States
initiates essentially because the
Islamic Republic is enriching uranium
there's not going to be a smoking gun
where we have intelligence that they're
actually trying to fabricate nuclear
weapons the International Atomic Energy
Agency is not going to differ is not
going to detect diversion of nuclear
materials from Iranian nuclear
facilities we're not going to have that
kind of causes belly if we go to war
it's going to be because we reach a
point in consultation with the Israelis
that we don't want the Iranians to go
any further in their own uranium
enrichment efforts it will have no
international legitimation there will be
no security council resolution that can
be even remotely construed as
authorizing it the sanctions resolutions
in place on Iran the Chinese and the
Russians have insisted that language be
put in there which makes it clear there
is no legal basis in these resolutions
for the United States to use force if we
do it we are going to be seen as a kind
of rogue superpower unconstrained by
international law international
institutions and it is going to have an
enormously negative imperative already
seen that way though um place it's going
to it's going to take it to a new level
that thing and I think it will also
raise further questions for countries
like China keep in mind if we fight
another war in the Middle East we're to
be fighting this one on barham money and
it's going to be money borrowed from
China from other countries that are not
going to be very thrilled to see a
military another military confrontation
in this critical part of the world are
they really going to be willing you know
to finance something that is from their
perspective so negative for their own
interests I think it's going to end up
creating real
for us internationally and the potential
for reveal it's going to be our own kind
of Suez moment and illusion in the
nineteen fifty-six who has crisis where
Britain overstepped and basically set
itself up for the end of any perception
of the United Kingdom as a real major
player in international affairs I think
it would do real profoundly negative
damage to America's international
position so avoid that I'd also say in
terms of the balance of power in the
region now it is critical that the
United States realign its relations with
the Islamic Republic of Iran as
thoroughly as comprehensively as we
realign our relations with the People's
Republic of China in the early 1970s at
this point in the evolution the regional
balance of power because of a lot of
different factors including American
mistakes we are in a position where we
now cannot achieve any of our own
high-priority objectives in this part of
the world in arab-israeli stuff in
providing energy security in Iraq and
Afghanistan we can't achieve any of our
own most important objectives without a
better more productive relationship with
Iran so I think that's critical to do I
think it's very important that we adopt
a genuinely regional strategy on
Afghanistan we are going to have to have
all the players in Afghanistan at the
table to come up with a legitimate
sustainable power-sharing arrangement in
that country and the only way we're
going to get there is if we have various
key regional players including Iran
helping us to organize that kind of
table now that's going to mean at what I
would call a genuinely regional strategy
I think we're also related to the idea
that will go back to offshore balancing
we have to get back to the idea that we
really are a strategically dominant
power which is providing real public
goods for people in the region for
people outside of the region you know
strategic primacy these
days is something which is very hard to
assert unilaterally it's something which
other players have to legitimate and I
think we need to get back on a track
through these various steps which will
help us rebuild some measure of
legitimacy for leading American role in
this part of the world in light of these
steps are things you just outlined what
do you think the best case scenario is
and the worst case scenario is in terms
of grand strategy in the Middle East the
best case scenario would be well if I
think if my recommendations were
followed I think you would see the
United States regain a good deal of its
strategic standing and influence in the
region it would be seen once again as a
as a power that was pursuing purposes
which a lot of regional constituencies
would be prepared to see as legitimate a
lot of international constituencies
would be prepared to see is legitimate
and we would restore a greater measure
of influence in this important part of
the region I think taking a very
different approach to the arab-israeli
arenas also essential to that that we
basically need a different kind of peace
process than we've got we have a kind of
Cinderella shoe peace process where if
you meet certain criteria that we define
we might let you come to the table but
it means we don't have the right people
at the table to reach a deal and if the
people at the table could reach any kind
of deal it wouldn't be sustainable it
wouldn't be implementable it certainly
wouldn't be legitimate so I think that's
another part of this really gitam a shin
of American power and influence in the
region the worst case scenario is we
basically stay on the track that we're
on and I think what when I say we're
headed toward strategic failure it means
that we're headed we are increasingly
um less and less effective at achieving
our own goals in this region the United
States is significantly less capable of
achieving its stated policy objectives
in the Middle East and the Persian Gulf
today than it was ten years ago you
extrapolate that out another five years
another ten years we may still have this
unique capacity to project a lot of
military power in the region but we are
going to be seen basically as a failed
hegemon a country which cannot achieve
its own purposes in the region and
cannot marshal other countries to work
with it to make they have these other
countries see our objectives as in some
way consistent with or supportive of
their own objectives and I think that's
going to be if that hat plays out that's
going to be a very very damaging blow to
America's global position what do you
think the reality of what actually will
happen Jake I'm sorry to say i'm not
particularly optimistic as an American I
hope I'm wrong in saying that but as an
analyst as a scholar I have to say I'm
not very optimistic a lot of reasons for
that the way our own domestic politics
is works as part of it I think coming
out of the Cold War americans believe
that they were on top of the world they
didn't really have to make strategic
choices they didn't really have to make
hard or difficult strategic calculations
of the sort you have to make to have a
really viable grand strategy and I think
that they are in some ways not just
politically we're not just politically
constrained but we're culturally not
very inclined to do it and basically out
of practice at doing it whether we can
recover get over those constraints yet
beyond those cultural
predilections and and and get back into
the business of doing real grand
strategy in time to avoid strategic
failure is an open question but I have
to say I'm not not overly optimistic
about it well very good thank you so
much for being here with us today and
sharing some of your work thank you for
more information about mr. Leverett and
his work please visit our website at
yale edu backslash macmillan report be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you